[Music]
now it's been a summer of animal stories
from geronimo the alpaca to pen
farthings dogs and cats it's often said
that britain is a nation of animal
lovers but has the last few months
showing that we've actually taken this
to the extreme two in five brits now say
that animal lives are worth just as much
as human lives
will more the spectator's features
editor rails against this moral
reprioritization in this week's
spectator cover article and he joined
spectator tv today together with the
animal rights campaigner dominic dyer
who has been on the forefront of these
animal welfare stories
will you write that these are signs of
moral collapse how say
the point i make about moral collapse is
it's it comes when
uh you put animal life at the expense of
human life that's where it's a problem
there is of course nothing wrong with
loving animals
i think the reason politicians always
say we're a nation of animal lovers is
because it is true and it is so
obviously true and that's a very good
thing
but
love can
uh go wrong um you could love um like
othello uh not wisely but too well and
and it's when
it's when love uh for animals gets into
the territory where where instead of
just caring for them and having high
standards of animal welfare which is a
very good thing
that
you start to treat animals as if they
have rights as akin to human rights and
that is where i think it gets very
worrying and that's where i think i i do
think it it it's a sign of moral
collapse because we're in a you get to a
stage whereby there's a lot of people in
this country who are much more concerned
with uh you know with animals and dogs
and cats and so on than they are with uh
you know
how the taliban treat women for example
because they that's what they have
that's what they are passionate about so
it's a point really about um public
perception uh i think more than anything
well there was that incredible yugov
couple that came out recently that said
actually two-fifths of people in the uk
actually think that animals lives are
worth as much as human lives well yes
exactly i mean so
that's yes that's a poll from last week
and uh that is a point about public
perception uh of events
um you know i'm sure dominique and i are
about to talk about operation arc uh but
my
my point really is it's it's it's bigger
than
operation arc itself it's how the public
responded to it that's what i'm really
was interested in with the piece it's
it's a it's a shift in public attitude
uh and
it's a shift that i think takes one
dangerous step too far it takes this
well-meaning uh instinct which is to
love nature to care for nature
uh
and it but it pushes pushes it into the
territory where by elevating animals um
and by humanizing them it actually has
an effect where um
uh people were dehumanized and that's
really what i was trying to get at with
the with the piece
yeah and dominic do you see this love
going into something a bit more sinister
no you know i've been involved in
whitehall and government and industry
and then on to wildlife and conservation
in my career so you know i've not come
this sort of far from
a perspective where i put animals before
people i think there is a huge caring
compassionate movement for animal
welfare wildlife protection in this
country and i think it's a very good
thing it makes me proud to be british
there's much that divides us politically
you know brexit and issues around
immigration and the economy and
everything else but actually you'll find
a lot of common ground between people on
the left and right of the spectrum when
it comes to wanting to protect animals
and i see the animal welfare movement as
being just as important in my view as
the anti-slavery movement the universal
suffrage movement the civil rights
movement and i think people who are
behind it and many are on the right
behind it this is not a movement that is
necessarily collected to the left you
know i can think of people andrea
jenkins mp i can think about trudy
pritchard who's been hugely influential
in operation arc i can you know rod
little your associate editor has been
helping me a lot on geronimo and also in
operation arc in recent weeks you know
this is a movement that has very strong
links in the right wing of politics in
in the conservative supporter base and i
think those people that read your
magazine and and understand many of the
issues you're concerned about are deeply
concerned about animals and and i don't
think we should underestimate that and i
think what we've seen with regards to
issues like geronimo and and operation
arc is is a a connection with people you
know people look at helen mcdonald and
think actually i can feel for her in a
relationship with that alpaca i feel for
her fighting with this government
department for five years just to get a
decent test to prove the animal doesn't
have tb and they were absolutely
horrified the way that debra went onto
that farm with people with hazmat suits
on that they come out of a nuclear
reactor and actually drag the animal
away there's no one would say that was
something that should happen in a
civilized society and when it came to
pen and operation arc remember that was
a humanitarian mission you know it
started with me because i sit on the
board of the royal college of veterinary
surgeons veterinary nurses council i was
very concerned about the veterinary
nurses about that you know young women
that have been trained given the
opportunities to do veterinary nurse and
veterinary work because of money that
was raised from britain and america you
know our soldiers died over 450 in that
war they they invested that with their
blood in their lives to give a
generation the opportunity to be
empowered not least women and that's
where that started and that's why it got
so much hold and that's why the royal
college of vet resurgence of british
veterinary association big businesses
like vets for pets all got behind it
wrote to the prime minister and it was
that that started it the animals were
just part of the picture we wanted to
rescue the animal rescuers and if we
could bring the animals with us as well
then that was something that would be
good and they'd all come off that plane
i don't think there would have been any
dispute about how wonderful that was out
of this terrible sad saga that was going
on in afghanistan so i think yes we have
hit a chord i think this summer has
shown how people care but i think it's
not just unique to britain you know if
you look at what's been going on in the
u.s in the last few days there's a huge
outcry now about dogs being left on the
runway at kabul airport the department
of defense took military dogs but it
didn't take contract to dogs and they're
left wandering around and the media are
all looking at them and it's going all
the way up to the white house and fox
news and a lot of commentators on the
conservative side of the debate in
america are really pushing this debate
to say that should never have happened
it would have left the dogs that penn
had on that runway you'd have had a
similar debate here in britain people
would have been going very angry indeed
and one final point i suppose and i
don't agree with this but a lot of
people that subscribe to your magazine
are on the right of politics probably
would rather have dogs coming in than
people i don't believe in that you know
i'm a believer in bringing people into
this country as refugees and settling
them because i think we have to do that
but there is a view maybe that animals
go before people in some people's minds
it's not something i share i think if
we're if we're good to animals we're
generally good to people and i think
that's a strong point in british society
we should be very proud of that i mean
i'm very glad you you uh you don't think
that uh we should put animals before
before people but i was struck in just
then um dominic when you when you did
compare the pet liberation movement to
slavery um which i just found a very
interesting comparison because i do make
the point in the piece that this
these comparisons between wanting to uh
to help animals but comparing to these
terrible uh uh
things that people in history had to had
to suffer through um i do think that has
a dehumanizing effect on people even if
that's not the intention i think that
that is what happens i mean in my piece
i mentioned uh peter the the animal
rights organization um the largest
animal rights organization in the world
and their 2003 holocaust on your plate
campaign where they juxta posed images
of uh battery hens alongside uh
concentration camp inmates with the
words
two
chickens or two hens perhaps i can't
remember no two animals i think to
animals all people are nazis uh and that
to me seems so
blatantly wrong even if that comes again
from a good place of wanting to look
after animals and treat them well
um when you're getting to that sort of
stage where where you're dehumanizing
people in that way um supposedly out of
benefit for animals i i do think that's
that's that's nasty and and i would also
say that the
um that yes you say that
you don't believe in prioritizing
animals ahead of people but i think what
the whole
saga i suppose um around operation arc
showed to me is that there are a lot of
people in the general public who
disagree with that which i find quite
dismayed i'm glad we both share the
opinion that that is a dismaying thing
but
we i i also mentioned in the piece this
call
uh made to lbc by a member of the public
who you know when asked if it really was
a choice between getting someone on the
plane
who's not an interpreter and getting a
dog on a plane you saying put the dog on
uh and she said yes uh and you could say
you know just the one member of the
public um you know it doesn't represent
wider beliefs however there is that uh
yougov poll uh putting uh
40 percent now of the public claim that
they see animal lives as
equal to
uh in worth
human lives so
it is it i think it is a growing trend
it is still a minority trend but it is a
growing one and i think that once you've
once you've crossed that line from
the very admirable causes of animal
welfare and but into the into the
territory where you want animals to have
rights as akin to human rights that's i
think very worrying
yeah you know we'll just sort of address
a few of those points you know i don't
agree with the comparisons between the
holocaust having a partner who lost
relatives in the holocaust you know and
having met many holocaust survivors and
studied that period of history very well
i'm not going to accept that we should
be making those comparisons so i don't
agree with what peta does in that area
um even though i know some holocaust
survivors have made those comparisons so
yeah they've got a right to do so if
they choose yes
bearing in mind what they've been
through um but if we look at the issue
of slavery for example and we look at
the unit the universal sub rich and
civil rights this was trying to improve
the rights of people and and and to move
society forward and i think what i'm
trying to say is that actually animal
welfare and animal rights is moving
society forward you know there's real
horror for example that we spend so much
time trying to improve the situation
with dogs and i work with many
conservative mps and ministers most
recently on trying to ensure that we get
uh mandatory checks on microchips before
dogs are euthanized we've had huge
support from the government on that and
i'm really grateful for it but it
strikes me that if we're taking so much
action to protect dogs that we have as
companion animals we still allow dogs to
be bred by american companies like with
this firm in in in huntingdon mbr
resources that actually breeds over 20
000 dogs in a facility in new york and
over 2 000 here to go into chemical
tests and i've worked in the industries
where these tests are undertaken they're
outdated they're outmoded mostly for
pesticides and household chemicals and
it's absolutely horrendous and quite
rightly now that you know pretty
patella's home secretary is being put
under pressure to look at why we have
regulations like that that force the use
of those types of animals it's the same
with using primates in animal
experiments i want to see that end i
think most civilized people would want
to see that end i think most civilized
people would want to see dog experiments
end and i think we should be moving in
that direction we should be proud that
we can bring that about i think in
relation to operation arc as i said you
know to me the only reason we got so
much traction with operation art was
because the dogs were part of the story
otherwise that group of afghans would
just be another group of people that
were faceless lists and you know their
emails never even opened in the foreign
office with hundreds of names but what
we're able to do is we're able to put
faces and their work with animals
together and really it was the animals
that would have got the people home if
you understand the logic of what we were
doing the animals would have got safe
passage for the people and to me that
was the story because they cared for the
animals they were the animal rescuers
would rescue them too and that's what we
were trying to do so we're making a
direct connection we weren't saying pets
before people that was something that mr
wallace and his political advisors in
mod came out with because they were
trying to delay the operation and i
think they got egg over their face
because other parts of government from
downing street down the foreign office
and home office could see what we were
trying to do and even defra and i have
my differences massively with them on
the killing of of geronimo the alpaca
were really helpful on all aspects of
getting those animals safely into the uk
and into into quarantine kennels where
they are so this idea that you know
we're trying to push an agenda that's
putting people second and animals first
i don't think that's the case what we're
trying to say is we move society forward
we improve the rights of animals we
improve the rights of people you know
there's a lot of evidence to show you
that when people are violent towards
animals you know if you want to go back
to the moors murderers and you see what
you know that was going on at that time
where cats and dogs were being killed
before they turned on children uh you
can see there's lots of evidence that
people that are psychopathic towards
animals and and kill them will take that
anger out on people as well so you know
compassion towards animals is something
we should welcome in our society it's a
good thing it means that we have less
violence towards people as well it makes
us a better society and i think britain
can be proud of the fact that
organizations like wwf started here
rspca compassion in world farming the
bourne free foundation and i work with
the virginia mckenna who's 90. that's
incredible and still does amazing work
in this area all of these people have
put britain on the map for being the
center of an animal welfare movement and
to be fair to the government they are
trying to capture that too with that
animal welfare strategy you know with
people working in government for zach
goldsmith with carrie johnson in downing
street with stanley johnson and all the
people that talk out on these things i
do think it's a good thing it's not
something to be negative about there are
huge challenges there'll always be
debates about where people come into
this and where animals come into it but
equally i think any politician that
underestimates the power of this growing
force as theresa may did in 2019 on the
hunting act and the ivory act she paid a
heavy price politically for that and
partly lost a majority because of it
boris johnson i think didn't make the
same mistake in
2020 elections sorry 2017 i'm talking
about theresa may but in 2019 boris
johnson didn't make the same mistake but
at the end of the day you know all of us
realize now this is a growing force in
politics and i'm happy to be part of
that yes it definitely is a growing
force in politics i mean i i i made that
point in in the piece i i think you're
completely right about that but i don't
think that necessarily
means that the the public shift in how
they perceive animals is
right even if it is popular i mean you
said there that the that
um the reason that people you know got
so invested in operation arc was the uh
because the animals were involved with
it and i think you're completely right
and i also think that's very dismaying i
mean i thought the most telling bit of
the whole thing was the um
when pen farthing and obviously under a
lot of stress um
sent that voicemail message that was
leaked to the government aid and i
thought the telling part about that was
when he said that he would um
uh he could turn the country against him
uh through social media and i think he's
right you know i think i think he didn't
he didn't even need to
to give that uh sort of order of um
attack because there were already people
who were
passionate and passionate enough about
the issue and worked up enough about it
to be doing uh that already and to be uh
harassing people involved in the
evacuation of kabul and i i do find that
pretty dismaying
um and then on the point you made a
point about primates and experimentation
um
and there was a very good point made by
baroness diet when talking about
criticisms of the animal sentience bill
and i think it was a good point which
was
that our covert 19 vaccines
um
they came into fruition because of early
experimentation on mice and ferrets and
primates and a primate is obviously and
it's a beautiful animal it's very um
advanced uh animal
in terms of sentience
but that
was an example you know if we didn't
have those vaccines now it's estimated
that as many as a hundred thousands more
lives could have been lost in this
country to covet would probably all
still be in lockdown which has greater
costs on on society in them on people's
lives and and their rights as as as
humans to to to you know leave their own
homes um and so that was an example
where
if if that if the primates had had
rights that meant
on a par with human rights that had
meant that they had couldn't have uh
these coveted experimentation on them
you know there's we would not have had
these vaccines or at least not had them
as fast as we had them uh in this sort
of race against time against the virus
so
that's a sort of another example in my
mind of where um you know you
the animal welfare in my mind is best
when it is trying to minimize
unnecessary suffering to animals i mean
the abhorrence of cruelty i think is a
it's a wonderful trait to have to abhor
cruelty
but
there are examples difficult examples i
think where where
suffering
is necessary with animals um in order
that human lives and human dignity
um
can be helped
and that's i'm very very just to come
back
but that is the experiment of the
situation i think
yeah just come back on the
experimentation issue because it's
important you make a fair point you know
primates we use a small number of
primates in an american university for
the uh um the astrazeneca oxford
university vaccine process and it wasn't
the case for the pfizer side of things
but the one thing we learned actually
with regards to what happened with those
vaccines is they move to human trials
really quickly the level of animal
expectant experimentation in relation to
those copied vaccines has been tiny
compared with other
non-pharmaceutical based you know
regulatory systems including for
household chemicals and pesticides and
other things and it shows actually when
the pressure is on and when government
regulators allow this to move to human
trials quickly we can get these
medicines to the market and we can get
them into people's arms in this case and
save you know millions of lives i think
the problem is not with the use of
animals it's with the regulatory system
that forces the use of animals i think
if you speak to most large companies i
used to work in the agrichemical
industry and i used to have this debate
all the time the companies i work with
did not want to use animals and
experiments but they were forced to use
them because of the regulatory system
that was in place and often they would
have disputes with the u.s regulators or
european regulators about the need to do
it so i think you know
it isn't a necessary evil that we have
to kill animals to do all these
experiments i think that the kovit 19
trials and the rapid move to get those
vaccines into people which has been
miraculous and i'm hugely grateful to
everyone involved as you are we all
should be um has shown that actually the
the level of
animal experimentation needed is is much
smaller than it has been in the past in
those processes and actually we can get
to to trial much more quickly with human
trials i think it's extremely good that
it's that it is lessening i mean that is
an excellent we can get there i think
the government are committed to that and
i think we will get there so i think it
is a step in the right direction but
just to come back on on the pen farthing
issue because i want to clarify that the
phone call because you know mr quentin
and the aide i spoke to mr quentin an
hour before penn made that phone call
and i tore a strip off mr quentin
without any expletives because i was
well aware of what he was doing in
whitehall to delay getting a flight
authorization working under the
direction of mr wallace and i said to
him we're having real problems here you
know unless we can get the authorization
via the ministry of defense to get into
that airport we're not going to be able
to get a contractor to fly in and the
number of aircraft that we have
available diminishing by the hour we
have the money to do this and i was
going from operators in istanbul to
operators in eastern europe to operators
in in the united arab emirates and cairo
and all of them were saying listen
you've not got us a flight number we
can't get you the plane and we can't get
you the plane it's not going to happen
so quentin was in the firing line he got
the criticism he deserved he was
muddying the waters with ministers i
made it very clear in a number of
interviews what happened with penn was
he was exasperated he was at the end of
his tether
his people were under risk he was on
direct risk yes he was under pressure so
he left a very expletive written
message i think most people in that
situation were probably done the same
quite frank and i think actually the
release of that the release of that tape
to the sunday times which had a long
discussion with them before they
published it i in my view was
fundamentally wrong and i've debated
with mr wallace and i'll continue to
about what he did on my issue can i can
i cutting here because we're running out
of time and fascinating discussion we're
having here but i just wanted you um to
respond to william will's point about
social media and the fact that the
content of that voicemail was penfolding
knowing very well what he could unleash
do you not think that i mean i know that
you're a keen user of twitter yourself
do you not think that a lot of this is
whipping up mob mentality in in a
sentimental way you know there's so many
animals who get put down because of tb
or you know so many animals that will
suffer in war zones but you know it's
social media that's really making it so
can i explain to you what what would you
have done in my situation okay we'd
worked all week you know the prime
minister had approved the visas for that
for people to leave the 68 through
pretty patel okay we had the whole of
defra working on getting the animals in
okay i had the money on the table from a
wealthy american investor in the united
stand spencer haber to get the plane
that we needed to get on the airport i'd
worked on it for 10 days and i had a
political aid suddenly in the shadows in
in whitehall in the ministry defense
basically telling ministers to back off
course i was angry you know what i do
yeah i did too can i just explain what
we did i took to social media okay and i
made a direct appeal to the prime
minister to say intervene after the g7
summit i made a little video on my phone
i got over 350 000 shares on it went
straight to downstream all the people
showing because yes they got actually
bombarded by it and at 1 50 in the
morning mr wallace clearly under huge
pressure from the prime minister put out
a tweet saying he changed his policy 360
degrees we could take the animals in we
could take the people in and we could
get the plane okay then i went on good
morning britain and i basically said
that you know this is a really difficult
time we need to get that plane on the
ground as soon as possible i was in
tears millions of people watching it and
then wallace blunders in and starts to
abuse me and say basically i was talking
nonsense i was abusing troops he was
slaughtered charlotte hawkins basically
pulled him up saying what are you doing
he'd been on the television radio the
day before saying we were talking
bollocks he was making himself look
stupid he was making downing street
extremely uncomfortable he was trying to
undermine the policy that the whole of
government had lined up to support and
ultimately ultimately he was endangering
lies because we couldn't get those
people through the gate and in the end
we didn't i hold him responsible for
that i've got to try and get them out as
others out of afghanistan that's a
bloody difficult thing and dominic grab
flying to pakistan today we've got
hundreds of other people that are in a
very dangerous situation i won't forgive
him for that he didn't need to delay
that flight the minute that he made that
tweet the minute the downing street
forced him to change i had the air
commodore ringing me directly in the
morning via his office to say dominic
you can have all the flight
authorization details you need just
passes on to your operators which i did
and we got it all sorted that could have
been sorted days before so that's why
that phone call was made from penfaving
that's why i ripped a strip off peter
quentin that's why i went to war with
ben wallace in the media and that's why
ultimately he lost
dominic dyer wilmore we'll have to leave
it there but thank you for joining
spectator tv
[Music]
you